Speaker 1: And another person.
Trumper point out there conning more people
this week, an inspector general appointed
by Donald Trump came out this week.
Saying that they did a thorough investigation
and it turns out that the PPE problems that
America had in the early days of the pandemic,
which seems like centuries ago at this point,
those PPY issues, it wasn't the fault of the
administration or the coronavirus task force
that he had put together.
No, sirree, it was FEMA.
It was all totally FEMA.
Homeland Security Inspector General Joseph
Kuffar came out and said this.
The magnitude of the global event exposed
weaknesses and FEMA's resource request system
and allocation processes, specifically Web
EOC.
The system FEMA used to process PPE and ventilator
resource requests, contained unreliable data
to inform allocation decisions and ensure
requests were accurately adjudicated.
In addition, although FEMA developed a process
to allocate the limited supply of ventilators,
it did not have a similar process for PPE.
There it is, folks.
Case closed, according to Mr. Ghaffari.
FEMA.
FEMA is to blame for how horrible things were
in the early days of the pandemic.
What I love about this is that this is complete
history, erasure.
We remember how things worked at that time.
You had Jared Kushner in charge of PPY, and
that didn't work out so well, you had PPY
that was being taken from some hospitals,
put over in these other places where Trump
and his little coronavirus task force would
then decide how to allocate it.
They were taking things from FEMA, not letting
FEMA do what they were supposed to.
We all know that those reports were everywhere.
This this is just mind blowing, and sometimes
you get a story like this that just shakes
you to your core because you know how false
it is, because, folks, we all lived through
this.
I know I said it feels like centuries ago,
but I'm hoping the more I say these things
that jog your memory and everybody's like,
oh, wait, yeah, I do remember that this was
crazy times.
It was the wild, wild west of PPY with our
own government acting as the bandits, taking
it from these places and reallocating it based
on where they felt it needed to go.
For example, in the early days of the pandemic,
New York was getting hit harder than anybody.
Florida was actually doing pretty well.
And this was, you know, March, April.
Twenty twenty folks.
But still they were sending all this ppy all
these ventilators down to the state of Florida,
and we had more than we could ever need down
here.
Meanwhile, New York was having to put people
in hospital beds, in parking garages without
ventilators because they just had nothing
and they were getting nothing.
And the difference is, obviously, New York
had a Democratic governor, Florida had a Trump
loving Republican governor.
It's really not that hard to put the pieces
together.
And yet here you have this report from kuffar
coming out and saying, nope, coronavirus task
force.
They did everything right.
FEMA screwed up because their computer systems
were stupid.
No, I'm not trying to absolve FEMA of any,
you know, any problems that they had during
the pandemic.
Sure, they had plenty.
Everybody had plenty, we weren't prepared
for this.
We had been cutting pandemic funding, we had
been cutting preparedness.
The Trump administration completely ignored
a response plan that the Obama administration
had put in place.
We had some protocols, certainly not even
enough, but we didn't even follow those.
So it is what it is covered, ran rampant,
still is rampant, is mutating at an alarming
rate at this point.
We're now getting reports out this week that
the lambda variant and I think whichever one
is after that, the other variant they mentioned,
they think those might actually be vaccine
resistant.
And if that is the case, we're back to square
one, folks.
We would be back to Lockdown's we would be
back to stay at home orders, mask mandates,
all of that from the beginning because our
vaccines.
Would be useless against new variants.
It is what it is, you know, we've we've elected
crazily incompetent people.
And we're reaping the repercussions of that.
And it's terrifying and yes, it's unfair to
the people who didn't vote for all of these
incompetent buffoons.
But nevertheless, every election can have
nationwide consequences.
You know, you may not live in Florida, you
may not have had the chance to vote against
Rhonda Santurce like I did.
But his idiotic decisions letting covid run
rampant here are still going to affect you
where you are, because the more we have it
here, the more it mutates, the more it travels.
Same thing with Abbott over in Texas.
Same thing with Hutchinson in Arkansas and
Ivy in Alabama and all of these other southern
states where it's blowing up, it's going to
make it back to the blue states, it's going
to make it to the West Coast, it's going to
make it to the, you know, Midwest.
All of these decisions from all of these politicians,
big and small, local and national, they all
affect each and every one of us.
FEMA screwed up in the beginning.
The White House coronavirus task force screwed
up even worse than that.
Trump screwed up, Governor screwed up.
Democratic and Republican Republican governors
hid covid data.
Cuomo to Santurce.
I'm looking at you both.
And we're still stuck in it, and as I mentioned,
we may be back to square one really soon.
But hey.
I appreciate you tuning in today and I appreciate
David Pakman and everybody else at The David
Pakman Show for letting me fill in again.
I am farand cousins.
You can get me on Twitter, Instagram, Facebook
at fair and balanced YouTube, Dotcom, the
Ring of Fire and my personal YouTube, YouTube,
Dotcom and balance.
Thanks for watching.
And stay tuned for today's.